Republicans debate unmasking the
original Trump Ukraine whistleblower
news stories circulate about Joe Biden's
family problems and Bill Gates shreds
Elizabeth Warren I'm Ben Shapiro this is
the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is sponsored by
expressive VPN your data is your
business protected at expressvpn comm
slash pen also when you get to the news
in just one second you may have been
noticing that things seem kind of
chaotic right now nobody knows which
direction the economy is going to go
there's a lot of political chaos there's
a lot of foreign policy cast what does
that mean it means a lot of people are
looking for a safe haven for their
investments because the stock market
tends to reflect world conditions when
there's a lot of chaos people move out
of sort of a safety and security feeling
about the stock market and investments
and instead they start looking at items
that don't lose value over time right
items that don't experience the same
sort of volatility depending on a
chaotic market and that would be things
like gold right you go to a place that
is a safe haven that has never been
worth zero this is where Birch gold
comes in gold is sitting at its
five-year high right now this makes
sense because again there is a lot of
chaos out there Birch gold can help you
answer all your questions about
investing in precious metals and then
help you do the investment itself if you
haven't taken the first step of
requesting a free information can on
gold you should do it it's free Birch
gold we'll go to work and make things
simple for you they'll have a
conversation with you you can determine
if precious metals make sense to include
in your portfolio again make sense for
my portfolio which is why I'm
diversified at least a little bit and
you should be too I know people that
burns called me working with them for
years they are trustworthy
again you should diversify that
portfolio text Ben - 47 47 47 today to
see how simple and straightforward this
move can be for you again that is Ben -
47 47 47 when you speak to them be sure
to ask what promotions they're currently
offering because they do have some good
stuff going on check out Birch gold
right now text Ben - 47 47 and 47 okay
we will get to the impeachment gate 2019
updates of the day because that is the
large majority of the news today but
first I want to give you a quick update
on what's going on tonight so tonight
I'm speaking at Stanford University and
should be a lot of fun in every year I
do the campus tour this year in this
quarter we haven't announced what's
happening in the next semester but this
semester we are speaking at Stanford
University as well as Boston University
and Baylor University and in each one of
these universities we have seen people
on the Left lose it over at Boston
University apparently they have been
adorning the flyers for my speech with
Hitler mustaches which is always
delightful because you know when you
take an Orthodox Jew and then label them
a Hitler that's that's never a bad look
at all and it's see what's in me I will
say it is
amazing so many of these social justice
warriors on the left the so-called
snowflake types are the people who are
so sensitive that they can't bear to
hear an opposing viewpoint and they're
really sensitive because if you say
something it hurts them right it's it's
so hurtful and the hurt I can't help it
just hurts so much they have to stand up
and have to they have to protest or they
have to they have to try and get you
cancelled right these same people whose
sensitivities are just like the all-time
high when it comes to the most blatant
violations of civic discourse they are
first and foremost now you can in
tribute to ignorance but they don't know
anything because this is particularly
true when it comes to stereotypes of
edges they don't know anything and they
don't care anything about that because
Jews are not an intersectional hierarchy
group for people who don't understand
intersectionality the original concept
of intersectionality has thrown out
there by kimberlé crenshaw this
professor made at least a little bit of
sons her argument was that there are
different ways people can be
discriminated against and if you check
the box in a couple of different
categories then you may be discriminated
against in more than one way so for
example if you're a woman maybe you get
discriminated in one way and if you're a
black woman maybe you get discriminated
against in another way because you're
discriminated against by virtue of being
above black and women now maybe that's
true right that argument is at least
plausible but what the intersectional
left has done is they've taken that
argument and then they have decided that
there is an intersectional hierarchy
that there are levels of victimhood in
American society and the more levels of
victimhood you check the more we should
value your opinion and more victimized
you are by American society well that
means that Jews don't rank right because
Jews are disproportionately well
educated Jews are disproportionately
wealthy Jews are disproportionately
living in in nice areas in the United
States they don't have severe family
problems as a general statistical rule
right and that means that they don't
list on the intersectional hierarchy
despite the fact that use our per capita
the group most likely to be targeted by
hate crimes in the United States for
example but the left doesn't care about
that the left thinks that Jews are not
part of the intersectional hierarchy and
that means they don't bother to learn
the offensive lingo they shouldn't be
using so the left is supremely sensitive
about any language that is used by
anyone reasonable and then they imply
that that language is exorbitantly
racist bigoted sexist homophobic alright
so for example if you say Western
civilization people on the hardcore
social justice warrior left
say what you actually mean by Western
civilization actually what you mean is
you mean white people I know alright
that's not what I mean if you say
judeo-christian culture like no it
sounds you by judeo-christian culture
you mean white people what what now say
say what that the so they're they're
they're its antennae are up
they're up everything's a dog whistle
for the left right when Donald Trump
said that this impeachment hearing is a
is a political lynching they immediately
went to all he means like black people
he's comparing himself to black people
being lynched in 1921 Tulsa that's what
he means it's like no he means the same
thing that Joe Biden meant when he
talked about Bill Clinton being
politically lynched in the late 1990s he
meant like you know the long history of
people in the United States of many
different races actually being killed
without proper try I mean that's so
that's what's remembered the antennae
are up except when it comes to the Jews
and you can see this in in perfect
perfect ways with regard to this this
one group at Stanford so they're holding
what they call the silent rally which
has got to be the most boring rally of
all time right what do you stand there
it's not even a die-in right like Diane
is dramatic you actually festoon
yourselves with makeup or something
a silent rally is I guess you just stand
there and then we're all supposed to
believe that you've been silenced even
though you have silenced yourself like
you can stand there and yell I'm not
stopping you enjoy yourself so they put
out a flyer about me and again it just
shows that the sensitivity is only
supposed to run in one direction okay
this was there at flyer we are tired of
Stanford administration's complicity in
putting black brown trans queer and
Muslim students at risk by allowing you
stand for college Republicans to bring
ben shapiro to campus so we'll start
with this particular point before we get
to the insanity of the the rest of the
flyer so this is a line that the left
likes to use a lot is that if they hear
something they don't like they have now
been put at risk they've been put at
risk when you've come in my speeches if
you've ever been to one of my college
speeches nobody's at risk at any point
people who disagree are allowed to go to
they're told that they should go to the
front of the line so that they can ask
questions everything is very respectful
everything is very civil and the fact
that they think that this is now putting
people at risk that it is it is
incitement my language is incitement by
virtue of the fact I disagree with it I
have never called for violence against
anybody this is complete insanity but
this is how they try and throw you off
campuses they say that
your language is inherently inciting why
because I say that transgenderism gender
dysphoria gender identity disorder is a
mental illness how is that inciting III
don't believe that people with mental
illness should be harmed in any way god
forbid that's ridiculous I'm talking
about the classification of a disorder
and it's categorized as a disorder in
the in the Diagnostic and Statistical
Manual okay in any case they continue we
do not protest because we are too
sensitive to hear opinions we don't like
we protest because we are strong enough
to defend ourselves well I'm pretty sure
it's because you're too sensitive to
hear opinions you don't like it it's not
just that you're protesting it's also
that you say that Stanford is complicit
in putting students at risk because I'm
saying sniffle gate but that's not the
best part of the amend says please wear
black if possible which I guess I'm not
I'm not sure why is it a funeral of some
sort in any case that's not the worst
part of this flyer so here is here's the
worst and also the best part of this
flyer so this flyer includes it includes
a spray bottle a graphic of a spray
bottle that says on it been be gone
silent rally Hoover tower 6 p.m. and
then below that there's a picture of me
and a picture of an aunt and a picture
of me and picture of a cockroach in a
picture of me and a picture of a potato
bug it looks like so I am literally
portrayed a Jew as an insect to be
exterminated oh ah the most sensitive
people on earth they're so sensitive ah
dog whistles everywhere and they're just
too openly saying this stuff I mean this
is the same kind of it is the same
graphic that was being used at like the
Rwandan genocide by people who wanted to
murder vast swathe through people they
famously the the who famously the the
groups in the one that were being
targeted on radio that were the ones
that were that were murdered they're
being targeted as cornhole cockroaches
sure you have an exact graphic of this
sort of thing right this is it's it's
like Nazi rhetoric and they put it on
the poster okay and then they issued
they issued some sort of apology which
is hilarious their apology is almost as
bad as as the bottle picture itself I
guess an aunt a flea and a Beatle on the
bottle so they issued an apology and in
the apology they call me an anti-semite
okay so the issue an entire flyer
talking about how terrible I am and how
terrible all of this is and then they
issue like this full there's no other
way to put it I mean that that image is
I'm not gonna say it's Anne siese
Medicaid certainly ridiculous okay it's
certainly ridiculous I think it's it's
ignorant and I'll credit them with
ignorance because I think they really
are stupid to put this on a on a poster
I think they're morons more than their
open anti-semites but then they they
apologize by calling me an anti-semite
in their letter it's it's beyond it's
beyond beggars belief at beggars belief
their apology says we would like to
apologize to the Jewish community for
the flyer put out with the been begone
bottle that resembled insect spray not
me they're not apologizing to me they're
apologizing to the Jewish community more
broadly we understand that this imagery
plays into anti-semitic tropes that say
Jews our insects and pests that need to
be exterminated this trope has been used
to justify violence against Jews in many
instances throughout history and is
never acceptable we sincerely apologize
for using this imagery well it was not
our intention to hurt anyone or invoke
Ben Shapiro's Jewish identity with this
flyer we hold ourselves accountable to
the impact of this imagery as a
coalition of concerned students that
includes Jewish students we are very
sensitive to anti-semitism
how are you though are you though
because he continued this way they say
therefore as we call back this flyer and
apologize for its anti-semitic tropes we
condemned Shapiro's Shapiro's unwavering
Islamophobia and anti-semitism
I'm the anti-semite you see not the
people who put in Orthodox Jew on an
extermination bottle of insects me I'm
the anti-semite you're that ox Jew who
keeps kosher just spent a month in
Israel keep Sabbath sends his kids to
Jewish school like I'm the aunt nail
that guy's nailed it right on the money
they say they reject my anti-semitism
because why am i a somatic they said
because of my belief that the only way
to be a real Jew is to agree with him
and through his strong support of
Zionism so my support of Zionism makes
me an anti-semite you say because I
support the existence of a Jewish state
I hate Jews if you can follow this logic
you should join this group and then you
should go wear black and silence
yourself cuz you're an idiot
really by the way I don't say the only
way to be a real Jew is to agree with me
I do but
that Judaism is a philosophy as well as
a religion and if you reject all the
tenants of the philosophy and the
religion then it's very hard to argue
that you are in any way consonant with
Judaism that's like saying that you're
not a real Christian if you reject the
divinity of Jesus or I mean that's it
seems like fairly obvious
they also say we reject Shapiro's false
belief in white Western supremacy that
he cloaks in the idea of judeo-christian
dizer now they're back to the dog
whistling I say judeo-christian values
and they say what I mean is white
Western supremacy white when am I ever
talked about white people being supreme
ever are you out of your minds the
answer of course is yes we will not let
been Shapiro's manipulative and hateful
language divide us they say we hope you
join us this Thursday my manipulative
and hateful language okay so that is the
update from Stanford I look very much
forward to speaking tonight at Stanford
University I think it's going to be a
blast
so we'll get to more on that in just my
plus I do have an update for you on a
story that of course made major
headlines across the country that is the
story of this kid in Texas who was
nearly handed over to his mom who was
basically prepping him for gender
transition at age seven and she said
she's gonna wait till he was 11 but
nothing stopped her from reinforcing all
of the kids supposed priors about being
a girl I have an update on that story
that's pretty amazing in just one second
first let's talk about the earbuds you
are using to listen to the show so
they're using those old fashioned
earphones you know the ones like from
1985 Marty McFly wears them always
riding a skateboard wearing those cuz
those are out of date you're wearing the
earphones the earbuds that have the
wires and you put them in a pocket and
then you take them out of your pocket
and they are all tied up like the
Gordian knot but if you cut it then you
ruin the earphones well instead you
should have wireless earbuds but you
don't need to pay a fortune for wireless
earbuds instead you should check out ray
cons ray con just released their best
model yet the e25 s they have six hours
of playtime seamless bluetooth pairing
more bass a more compact design that
gives you a nice noise isolating fit ray
cons wireless earbuds are so comfortable
they're perfect for on-the-go listening
and for taking phone calls unlike some
of your other wireless options ray con
earbuds are both stylish and discreet
there are no dangling wires and there
are no stuns you should go get them
right now and don't spend a fortune
because ray cons are not gonna cost you
the same as other companies and they
sound great now is the time to get the
latest and greatest from Ray Khan get
15% off your order at Buy rate con comm
slash pen that is B you IRA Y Co n comm
slash man for 15% off rake
wireless earbuds by rakin comm /
Bennigan's by Rick hun comm / meant for
15% okay so quick update on this case in
Texas and then I promise we will get to
all of the improvement gay
20:19 updates okay so here is the update
according to Amanda press the Shaka MOU
over at Daily wire a seven-year-old boy
whose mother claims he's actually a girl
named Luna recently chose to go to
school as himself a boy named James now
that his father has been granted equal
say in his transition
two weeks ago Telus judge Kim Cook's
ruled that dr. Angeles and mr. Jeffrey
younger James's parents have joint
managing conservatorship and joint
decision-making over their boys James
also has a twin brother named Jude both
G or glass a pediatrician and younger
had gag orders placed on them by Judge
cooks barring them from speakings the
media in the case of course gained
national attention after a jury decided
that one guardian should have sole
conservatorship over James and that
person should not be mr. younger while a
third party yesterday posted on Facebook
a picture of James going to school as
James says going to school this is what
it looks like when James gets to choose
a firm this also a photo taken yesterday
just before church James and Jude proud
to be men saved James saved thousands of
children in an update it was noted that
mr. younger emailed the principal on
Monday and James and Jude teachers had
reported there was zero stress or
disruption in the classroom today just
another day in school prayers answered
the updates concluded as you know Joerg
less argued that James was actually a
girl because James said that he was a
girl and there was testimony from the
father that mom had basically been
telling him he was a girl since the age
of three and reinforcing all of his
gender confusion younger said that his
ex-wife would in his opinion only show
James love and affection when he would
present as a girl he also posted a video
that we played on the show of James at
3:00 telling younger that mommy tells
him he has a girl jurgis had complete
authority over the psychological and
psychiatric care for the boys prior to
the judges October 23rd ruling but the
fight over James is not over according
to the Dallas Morning News and now G or
Gillis is seeking to have judge cook's
recused so he's going after the judge
why because the judge
tweeted out or put out on Facebook an
article from the Dallas Morning News and
captioned it the governor nor any
legislature had any influence on the
court's decision basically saying yeah
we're an independent court and the fact
that Greg Abbott said that he would step
in and investigate had nothing to do
with what the court actually ruled here
before younger was hit with a gag order
he told LifeSite news reporter madeline
jacob his ex-wife contemplated quote
cutting the penis off james in an email
presented to the jury he said the Texas
I grew up in the Texas I live in if a
parent did that we're just gonna give
him the child the to the other parent
we're not gonna tolerate that kind of
craziness it tells you how far our
society has changed well if that story
is accurate if this is all accurate that
James is now going to school as a boy it
does give the lie to the idea that
somehow this kid invariably identified
as a girl that parental behavior has no
impact on child behavior I mean it's an
insane idea in the first place that
parental reaction to child behavior has
no impact on how children act that's
asinine anybody who has kids knows that
so we'll keep you updated on that case
as updates become available okay
meanwhile the latest in impeachment
gates wants you 19 so the left is trying
to dredge up basically I think that
there's a game that's now being played
by the left on impeachment gate on the
one hand they're suggesting that there
is a that there is an actual issue with
Trump's Ukraine behavior that is
impeachable and they're they're asking a
bunch of questions that bring in people
to testify they're running what is in
effect a normal impeachment process I
know that a lot of people on the right
said that the impeachment process is not
normal that the process is skewed okay
there is some truth to that I mean they
did a lot of this behind closed doors
they did not actually comply with the
same sort of procedures that they did
with regard to the Clinton P from but
now they're doing a lot of open doors
hearings next week they have vowed that
they are going to open the doors and do
a bunch of different hearings apparently
those hearings are going to include
hearings with William Taylor the
ambassador bill Taylor who was the
highest-ranking Ukrainian official from
the United States during this entire
period Taylor has been militants in his
belief that President Trump was
attempting to engage in a quid pro quo
with the Ukrainian government to benefit
himself politically they're also going
to interview George Kent and they're
also going to interview Mary yovanovich
who was the ambassador to Ukraine who
the best information seems to suggest
was ousted because Trump didn't trust
her and maybe didn't trust her because
Rudy Giuliani was telling him not to
trust her Adam Schiff announced these
hearings they said that the the
Wednesday hearing will feature bill
Taylor and George Kent and then next
Friday they'll hear from Mary yovanovich
so the impeachment hearings are moving
forward in a sort of if not
normal than close to normal way right
this is the way that the process
typically sort of works okay but then
there's another track that Democrats and
the media seems to be pushing and that
is trying to get inside Trump's head by
trying to trigger him to do something
and frankly it's a smart if nefarious
strategy one of the things that you saw
from the second half of the Mullen
report is that President Trump is
reactive to the media coverage of him
he's extremely reactive to the chaos
that he senses around him so if he feels
as though the media are targeting him he
is more likely to fly off the handle
according to the Mullen report and then
he is more likely to say things like and
get himself in trouble in other words
when you put pressure on Trump he tends
to lash out and exactly that sort of
lashing out is what Democrats are
looking for because what they would like
for Trump to do is appear to be
obstructing the investigation appear to
be involving himself in further to law
breaking activity because here's the
truth
it's going to be very difficult for them
to prove that Trump engaged in any sort
of law breaking with regard to his
Ukraine activity now may be bad it may
be wrong it may be something a president
shouldn't do but in order for them to
determine that President Trump has
committed a crime they actually have to
fulfill statutory definitions of bribery
and that's very difficult it's gonna be
difficult to prove that even folks on
the Left acknowledge this even if they
were to come up with a serious abuse of
power what they would basically have to
do in that case is they would have to
show full intents by Trump to get Joe
Biden in advance of the 2020 election
not intent by Trump to target political
opponents from 2016 out of ire over 2016
right one of those has crossover with
American interests we just spent two and
a half years investigating whether
Russia interfered with the American
election so if we get to investigate
that why would we not get to investigate
whether Ukraine interfered in the 2016
election or to condition Ukrainian aid
on their investigation of corruption I
mean Joe Biden allegedly did just that
and that was totally fine so in order
for Democrats to prove actual wrongdoing
here they have to prove intent proving
intent with Trump is a tricky business
it's a very difficult thing this is what
the Democrats found out in the second
half of the Moller report that's why
they didn't impeach over the second half
of the malla report because basically
the second half of the Moller report
said Trump was fulminating about Muller
all the time he was ordering members of
his of his cabinet to issue letters to
other members of his cabinet telling
them to do certain things and then those
things were being rejected and so
Democrats could have pushed impeachment
but Trump Allah said listen I didn't
have the wreck
intend to shut down the investigation I
didn't shut down the investigation I had
the full power to do so and I didn't do
it so difficult for you to claim intent
well same thing applies here
so instead Democrats are trying to push
Trump to make a mistake now hey not six
months ago not three months ago now
they're trying to push Trump to do
something now that will lead Trump into
an obstruction trap or into a perjury
trap onto something that will create an
impeachable offense moving forward
because they actually don't have the
goods moving backward and this is why
you are seeing the media start to
manipulate their coverage to basically
elicit a response that will be wild from
Trump that also happens to benefit them
electorally right I mean the wilder
Trump looks the worse it's gonna be from
in 2020 right now
whoever is the adult in the room in 2020
is likely to win because nobody nobody
who is center-to-center right wants to
vote for Elizabeth Warren all Trump has
to do is appear to not be crazy and who
will win all Democrats have to do is
appear not to be crazy and they will win
and right now both are failing so
Democrats aren't attempting they they
understand they're not gonna make
Elizabeth Warren insane so instead what
they have decided to do is make from act
crazy and the story they are using today
to do this is this story from anonymous
so remember there is a New York Times
op-ed writer who wrote anonymously
supposed to be a member of the Trump
administration and now that person has
written a book and the book is supposed
to be about how Trump is just the worst
the book is called a warning okay well
now Huffington Post journalist yeah
Charlie has reported on Wednesday night
that the book claims that Mike Pence the
vice president of the United States was
fully prepared to go along with the
invocation of the 25th amendment to
remove the President of the United
States for mental incapacity now there's
a lot of talk about this in left-wing
circles immediately after Trump's
election that Trump is so crazy he can't
be President the cabinet will oust him
on the basis of the 25th amendment that
he's incompetent and that he has to be
put aside if you know Mike Pence if you
know anything about my Pence the idea
that Mike Pence was telling anyone
around him that he was ready to get rid
of Trump over the 25th amendment that is
patently ludicrous it is insane but the
media been pumping this story anyway
without with a serious man with it with
the serious amounts of credulity like
this Clinton does not warrant credulity
in fact this claim basically undermines
the entire credibility of the anonymous
person who wrote this particular book
nakorn be our lead a much-anticipated
book a warning reportedly written by an
unnamed senior White House official
claims that high-level White House aides
were certain that VP Mike Pence would
support the use of the 25th amendment to
have President Donald Trump removed from
office because of mental incapacity the
source that provided the excerpts it did
so on the condition of anonymity so it's
an anonymous source providing stuff from
an anonymous book by an anonymous person
inside the Trump administration so now
we are now three levels of anonymity
removed from reality according to The
Huffington Post according to anonymous
there was no doubt in the minds of these
senior officials that pence would
support invoking the 25th amendment if
the majority of the cabinet signed off
on it the discussions about invoking the
25th amendment took place according to
the book soon after FBI director James
Comey was fired by the president
Katie Waldman the press secretary for
pens too responded to the news report by
tweeting fake news atop from Poway in
the White House responded to the report
told the Daily where whoever anonymous
is assuming this is actually in the book
has exposed themselves as a complete
fraud
anyone who knows the VP knows he would
never tolerate such talk and any such
person would be immediately shown the
door mark water the Trump 2020 director
of strategic communications responded to
the story writing on Twitter this is the
dumbest thing I've ever read I served as
vice president's press secretary at the
time anyone who gives this nonsense any
credibility does not know Mike Pence by
the way even leftist journalists and
censor journalists were saying like this
is crap Jonathan Swan of Axio says
anybody who covers pence knows this is
an absurd claim well Jonathan's a good
reporter and that is a hundred percent
true Washington Post White House
reporter Josh Taos he also agreed said
what mr. Swann said obviously that's
true but the goal of these sorts of
stories is not of course to illuminate
the situation in the White House is to
get inside Trump's head and to get
inside Trump said because the belief is
on the left the more you get inside
Trump's head the more likely he is to be
volatile and to do something that will
harm him in this whole impeachment saga
ends in the 2020 election and listen I
think Trump has reason to be suspicious
I do I think he has reason to be
suspicious of people surrounding him his
administration Denix an insanely leaky
the media have been given extraordinary
access to stuff they should not have
access to in any normal administration
I'll get some more of this in just one
second first let's talk about you
getting ready for work in the morning
okay well when you get ready for work in
the morning typically that means if
you're dude you got
he's gonna shower the whole deal and
when you get those goods means you got
to go to the store you got it when you
run out you got to go to the store you
got a pick between a thousand different
goods some of them are good some of them
are bad or theoretically you could just
have the stuff delivered to your door
yet best quality products very very
easily and this is where Dollar Shave
Club comes in Dollar Shave Club helps to
make your life easier taking the
guesswork out guaranteeing quality
shaving products
shower shave club by the way is way more
than just razors they've got you covered
head to toe they've got everything you
need to shower shave style your hair
brush your teeth it's a one-stop shop
for all of your grooming needs they've
got amazing something like their amber
lavender body cleanser it is calming it
is soothing they've got that the hair
styling gel like all sorts of great
stuff
teller shave club can keep you
automatically stocked up on the products
you use you get what you want whenever
you need it whether that's once a month
or a few times a year I never have to
waste time in a store wondering if what
I'm getting is any good I don't
necessarily right now you can put the
quality of Dollar Shave club's products
to the test
their ultimate shave starter set has
basically everything you need for an
amazing shave they've got the executive
razor shave butter prep prep scrub post
shave do the best part is you can try it
for just five bucks after that the
restock box ships regular sized products
at regular prices get your ultimate
starter set for just $5 at
dollarshaveclub.com slash pen that is
dollarshaveclub.com slash pen go check
them out right now in tyler save
club.com slash pen okay so as I say the
strategy of the left getting under
Trump's skin it's not a bad strategy it
isn't a bad strategy because the fact is
that Trump has a rationale for being
pretty suspicious of the people who are
coming after him so the their tweets now
that have emerged from the
whistleblowers lawyers so remember the
whistleblower in this case right the
whistleblower in this case is the person
who first reported the Trump Ukraine
phone call reported up the chain and
then there were pretty serious and I
think pretty well substantiated
allegations that the whistleblower was
coordinating with Adam Schiff steam and
then it started to come out that this
whistleblower whose name has been named
I mean we mentioned it on the show right
we use it allegedly right John Solomon
at the hill reported it the guy's name
allegedly is eric tarr amela it's not
illegal for me to say that let me just
point that out it's not illegal for me
to say that it's not illegal for Trump
to say it it's not illegal for anyone's
you say it except for the Inspector
General of the of the intelligence
community apparently okay and that's not
according to me that's according to NPR
NPR says in recent days President Trump
allies have amplified their calls for
the whistleblower who sparked the
impeachment inquiry to be identified
presenting the question of whether it
would be a crime for the president to
unmask the anonymous whistleblower now
let me make clear the whistleblower laws
are meant to protect the job of the
person they're not meant to protect the
anonymity of the person they're meant to
protect the job so you can't fire the
guy which is appropriate when someone
blows the whistle you shouldn't fire him
you shouldn't be able to fire them but
it's not meant to protect their
anonymity and that makes sense because
what if the anonymous whistleblower is a
partisan hack and that has some
ramifications for things that matter for
the country like say impeachment
according to robert litt former general
counsel for the Office of the Director
of National Intelligence under Barack
Obama he says a firm thinks he knows the
name he can come out and say it he's
probably as protected as anyone is lit
and several other legal experts who
talked to NPR said that Trump uttering
or tweeting the name could in theory
trigger an article of impeachment for
retaliate against a whistleblower that'd
be kind of rough but it would not run
afoul of any federal criminal statutes
similarly if a news outlet member of
Congress remember of the public outed
the whistleblower legal expert said no
criminal law would be violated dan Meyer
lawyer and former executive director of
the intelligence community whistleblower
program says there's no overarching
protection for the identity of the
whistleblower under federal law Congress
has never provided that protection now
again is it relevant to the
consideration of the American people who
the whistleblower is and how this whole
thing came about I mean it is I think
it's important though it's not
dispositive I ok for people on the Left
who don't understand the word
dispositive this positive means it is
not sufficient to get rid of the charges
against President Trump to point out
that the whistleblower is a hack and the
whistleblower can be a hack and his
allegations can be true and troubling
right both of those things can be true
but in calculating for the American
public whether this is in fact a
good-faith attempt to impeach a
president on the basis of constitutional
violations or whether this is a put-up
job by Democrats seizing on a violation
by President Trump allegedly of the
Constitution or official duty you got to
know the mode it's funny to me to watch
the media pretend the motivation of the
people behind this thing doesn't matter
when they ran along with the motivations
of the people behind impeachment are bad
for literally years during the Clinton
impeachment stuff and I'm old enough to
remember when James Carville was saying
about Paula Jones that if you drag on
$100 bill for a trailer park they'll
come up with people like Paula Jones
James Carville worked for the president
at the time was that maligning accusers
I'm old enough to remember when Hillary
Clinton went on national television and
accused Kenneth Starr of being part of a
vast right-wing conspiracy and Linda
Tripp and everybody else vast right-wing
conspiracy did the media really suggest
that that was SuperDuper wrong
so Trump is doing the same thing here
it's exactly the same thing you may not
like it it's hard-nosed politics it's
smashmouth politics and is usually the
way these things go hey and that is only
gonna be exacerbated by the fact that
the identity of the whistleblower again
who was mentioned by jöns Holloman is
Italy alleged identity the guy
apparently was an Obama acolyte I've
worked with Joe Biden worked with James
clapper was staffed in the White House
in the Trump White House and then was
thrown out and apparently went back to
the CIA base at Langley after people in
the White House suspected he was leaking
the media and now it comes out that mark
Saeed who's one of the attorneys
representing the Intel community
whistleblower tweeted in January 2017
quote a coup has started an impeachment
will follow ultimately he tweeted will
get rid of him and this country is
strong enough to survive even him and
his supporters he also tweeted as one
Falls two more will take their place
apparently referencing the Trump
administration employees who defy the
White House
xayide promised that the coup would
occur in many steps so should Trump be
suspicious yes I mean here's President
from last night at a rally saying yeah
the whistleblower the whistleblowers
lawyer was plotting a coup from the very
start and I mean those tweets say what
the tweets say okay they just hand me
the story who has started whistleblowers
attorney said in 2017 you know when that
was that was a long time ago it's all a
hoax they say January 2017 a coup has
started and the impeachment will follow
ultimately Toula
it's all a hoax it's a scam and you know
who helps them these people right back
here the media okay imagine that Paula
Jones his lawyer had said back in 1995
that a coup has started against
President Clinton how do you think the
media would treat that do you think that
they would absolutely uphold the end in
Ahmadiyya Paula Jones if she insisted on
remaining anonymous the answer is likely
not likely not so is Trump suspicious of
all this yeah should he be suspicious of
all this yeah
gonna lead him to make volatile
responses maybe and this is why she
should be careful and this is why again
the people around him they need to say
no to him sometimes okay what the mullah
report showed is that when Trump does
stuff that's crazy people around him
have to say no the problem with the
Trump Ukraine stuff is that apparently
nobody around him just said mr.
president no right that that is that
sort of John Kelly's claim the former
chief of staff and that seems plausible
he'll get some more of this in just one
second because the media are making hay
out of how dare Trump go after the
whistle blower how dare Donald Trump jr.
mention the name of the whistleblower
and if the if the parties here were
reversed I have very very little doubt
that the media would be outing this
whistleblower inside of 30 seconds
inside of 30 seconds we'll get to that
in just one second first it's really
important to invest when you're young
have you ever taken a look at those
charts that show you the age you start
investing and how quickly the wealth of
Cruz if you start investing I know a lot
of people who listen to the show are
actually disproportionately young you
need to start investing now but how
should you go about doing that well I
have a great way for you to go about
starting to invest that would be so if I
invest getting your money right doesn't
have to be hard yet access to so Phi's
financial advisors who can answer any
questions you have at no cost because
taking control of your investments
shouldn't be intimidating the fact is
Millennials are under invested but you
should get started right now so so if I
invest makes it incredibly easy for
anyone stuck to start investing with as
little as just like a buck really like
honestly like put a dollar in now and
it's going to matter you can even buy a
piece of companies like Amazon Google or
Disney with so if I stock bits at
whatever amount you want which is a
super cool thing right you want to
invest in a brand name stock we don't
have a couple grand lying around to buy
one share of Amazon or something instead
you can buy a stock bit and now you own
a piece of Amazon but the amount that
you can actually afford to pay for
there's not an excuse to avoid
investment any longer check out sofa
comm slash Ben and create an account
you can choose to either do it yourself
or you can let so Faiz automated
investing build your portfolio for you
you can use those stock bets to buy
fractional shares your favorite stocks
and start with as little as a buck
compound interest is the most magical
thing in finance go invest right now see
for yourself how easy it is to start
investing with sofa at Sophie comm slash
Ben again fund your sofa investing out
and right now you receive 25 bucks in
mystery stock these are brand-name
stocks or bits of brand-name stocks
that's free stock just for signing up go
to sofa comm slash bin to claim your
free stock today that is sof i.com slash
man again s o fi com slash man so file
ending Corp CFL number
six zero five four six one two okay in
just one second we're gonna get to more
of impeachment kay 2019 and the media
frenzy over outing The Whistleblower how
dare we out the Elizabeth I'll get to
all that in just one second first if
you're not already a subscriber you're
really missing out head on over to tail
e wire.com slash subscribe for as little
as ten bucks a month you got our
articles had free access to all of our
live broadcasts our full show library
select bonus content our exclusive daily
water app pretty amazing feature if you
haven't acted out yeah I mean we spend
serious kuan on building this thing and
it is beautiful if you choose the new
All Access plan you even get that plus
the legendary leftist yours tumbler whoo
magical and our brand-new asked me
anything style discussion feature it
allows you to engage our hosts writers
and special guests on a weekly basis so
stop depriving yourself come join the
fun also one of the great things he got
when you subscribe you get our Sundays
specials on Saturday this week super
excited to welcome to the program the
inimitable world-famous George Will who
stopped by for a delightful hour what
what what a great dude he is you're
gonna wanna it's a fascinating
interesting discussion about his new
book about conservatism and about the
role of the government and the role of
the judiciary it's big ideas and
interesting ideas I loved this
discussion I think you will too here's a
little bit of what it sounded like
politics is dangerous there's no safe
harbor police could become Gestapo
taxation could become confiscation but
we need police and we need taxation
there is no safety in politics life is
lived on a slippery slope get over
[Music]
amazing stuff it's really really good
you're gonna love it go check it out
right now subscribe to get all of those
benefits plus you're protecting the
content you love from the left that
wishes to destroy that content I mean as
we noted at the top of the show the left
they're more interested in silencing
than they are in discussion so you can
protect the content you love by
subscribing it really does help us out
and make sure that we can continue to
bring you the best in conservative
content we are the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
you
all righty so let me just note for the
record you and I talked about the press
and their unwillingness to out
whistleblowers like their standards
their standards and practices we are not
going to mention the name of this
whistleblower let me tell you a story
let me tell you a story I mean this is
the story of a CBS News staffer who was
just fired
why was the CBS News staffer just fired
right by by our illustrious media by our
illustrious media why was this CBS News
staffer fired well because it turns out
that this CBS News staffer was the
source of the video from ABC News of an
anchor talking about how the ABC News
brass stopped a story on Jeffrey Epstein
yeah Sharlee really good reporter a good
dude here was his thread that's what are
you ready for this scoop ABC News execs
believe they know who the former
employee is who is accessed who accessed
footage of amy robach expressing her
frustrations about her shelves Jeffrey
Epstein story that former employee is
now at CBS and ABC executives have
reached out to CBS News executives in a
statement an ABC News spokesperson tells
me we take violations of company policy
very seriously and we're pursuing all
avenues to determine the source of the
leak it's important to note that ABC
News does not know if this former
employee leaks the footage to Project
Veritas what they do know is who access
the footage it's possible that person
could have shared it with others who
leaked it as I noted in this thread ABC
News has confirmed they're conducting an
investigation into the leak in response
to an email CBS News says they're
declining to comment for the story
update two sources familiar with the
matter tell me that CBS News has now
fired the staffer in question this comes
after ABC informed CBS that they had
determined who accessed the footage of
Amy Wroe batch expressing her
frustrations about the Epstein story so
just just to point out the insane
contrast here the same media who are
saying we cannot know that yet we must
never mention the identity of the
whistleblower who initiated an
impeachment inquiry into the President
of the United States we have to keep his
name locked up under lock and key we're
not protecting his job he's protected he
can't be fired he's a federal employee
can't be fired but we're protecting him
because that's the right thing to do ABC
News just went to CBS News a completely
different company right they're not the
same company ABC News went to CBS News a
competitor and said to CBS News you know
one of your employees that person leaks
footage from us
to other members of the of the media on
the conservative side and CBS said you
know what you're right we're firing him
what what so amazing amazing really
protecting your whistleblowers over
their media Stephen Miller not that one
from the administration read Steve Zahn
on Twitter he says to news networks
colluding to fire someone who leaked a
massive bombshell about one of them
covering up for a highly connected
pedophile now watch his journalists all
turn away so as not to endanger their
own future job prospects but sure guys
truth to power or something guessing
there won't be a ton of drum banging
about this whistleblowers rights uh yeah
ya think so when when you hear the media
getting all hot and bothered about the
facts that that Donald Trump's son
tweeted out a link to Breitbart that
named the the alleged whistleblower and
the meeting oh that's so terrible how
could this happen
oh it's again he didn't violate a law
Rand Paul was pointed this out NPR has
pointed this out no law was violated is
it in the interest of the American
public to know who initiated an
impeachment inquiry into the President
of the United States I think so don't
you now again it doesn't answer all the
questions that the whistleblower
provides doesn't answer the allegations
by Bill Taylor it doesn't answer the
allegations about about Murray Ivanovich
and it's important to note that those
people right the ones that the Democrats
are painting as Patriots all of them are
patriots we know that cuz we know their
names right we know what they do we know
who they are we don't know anything
about the whistleblower except that
which has been reported by John Solomon
and Breitbart and then the fact is that
the media have not dug into the story
because if they dig into the story they
may come up with some answers they don't
like so the AFP for example could not
intend independently verify the
whistleblowers identity is not
publishing the name weird because it
seems like the entire press was happy to
run with Brett Kavanaugh as gang rapists
on the basis of Michael avenatti saying
a bunch of crap
pretty amazing what my favorite is that
they say that they're not going to name
the names because they're afraid for the
guy's safety so just to recap they will
fire a person who leaked information
relevant to public discussion from a
different network but they're afraid to
leak the name or talk about the name of
a whistleblower who is not protected by
law when it comes to anonymity they
won't discuss the name or the identity
or anything about
we'll do it because it might put his his
it might put him at physical risk okay
these are the same people who have outed
people who made memes on Twitter I mean
somebody made a meme of President Trump
tackling like the CNN headed cartoon on
Twitter the media out of that guy when a
guy named Carson King in Iowa committed
the egregious sin of giving a million
dollars to charity after he held up a
sign and a college football game and
received a million dollars from people
offering to buy him beer the media
promptly outed him went back to his old
tweets and tried to destroy his
reputation but these they're super
concerned however about the safety of
the whistleblower I'm sure I'm sure
that's what it has nothing to do the
partisanship it must be that you are
suddenly concerned about the safety of
people's private information
I trust the media when it comes to this
stuff they're always concerned about
this sort of stuff according to Vanity
Fair though that's their excuse to name
or not to name that is the question that
may soon bear down on mainstream news
organizations as Donald Trump's ally
step up the pressure to make the Ukraine
whistleblowers identity public as in all
over cable news and on the front page of
the New York Times type of public so far
as political reporter Tuesday mainstream
news rooms have been unified in their
resistance to naming the whistleblower
whose anonymity is meant to be protected
by law now again they say his anonymity
is meant to be protected by law
literally not true not true his job is
meant to be protected by while his
anonymity is not specifically meant to
be protected by law on Monday night Rand
Paul implored the media do your job in
Printz his name on Wednesday Donald
Trump jr. raised the stakes he tweeted
the alleged whistleblowers named along
with a link to a Breitbart article he
told you I Sharlee the outrage on this
is BS those pretending that I would
coordinate with the White House to send
out a Breitbart link haven't been
watching my feed for a long time the
Drudge Report screamed jr. outs the
whistleblower but apparently the The
Drudge Report had previously linked to
an article to mention the whistleblower
so there's that as well so it again it's
amazing to watch it that suddenly the
violation of privacy is a big deal to
the media that don't care about privacy
at all except when it applies to
apparently one side of the aisle
representative Jim Jordan for his part
he is on the Intelligence Committee and
he says that we are going to we are
going to question this whistleblower six
weeks ago shed the whistleblower would
testify and that he must have to fight
remember what happened is that the
whistleblower report the existence of a
came out then the transcript came out
the transcript didn't back everything
that Democrats were claiming right it
didn't say explicit quid pro quo it
didn't make clear that the Ukrainians
even knew that military aid was being
withheld or any of that and then ship
said well we're gonna get the
whistleblower to testify then a bunch of
other people came forward and said what
shift wanted the whistleblower to say
and then he was like well I guess we
don't have to have the whistleblower
testify anymore
well according to Jim Jordan he has a
piece in the in USA Today he says six
weeks ago Schiff said the whistleblower
would testify he has now changed his
mind what happened in the interim just
two things we learned the individual met
with shift staff and we learned about
their political bias the whistleblower
only knew about the call from the
characterizations of others
he waited 18 days before filing a
complaint with the Inspector General
during those 18 days the whistleblower
met with shift staff but failed to
disclose this communication to the
inspector general Schiff also hid this
meeting Americans understand fairness
they know when someone is getting a raw
deal the impeachment push they send this
anonymous and secondhand complaint is
fundamentally unfair and then and then
Jim Jordan says President Trump and
zalenski and President zalanski of
Ukraine affirm there was no quid pro quo
no no pressure the transcript of the
call shows no conditionality at the time
of the call Ukraine's did not so no
security aid was delayed and Ukraine
never took any of the actions it was
supposed to take under pressure and the
Trump administration turned over the aid
so that is that is at least a partial
defense meanwhile the Democrats continue
to maintain that the identity of the
whistleblower is sacrosanct so nothing
is sacrosanct except that apparently so
that is where things currently stand
meanwhile you know for all the people
who talk about the Trump administration
basically just being a proxy for Trump
himself and ripping into Attorney
General William bar who's supposed to be
a political hack a massive political
hack well it turns out that according to
the Washington Post President Trump went
to Attorney General bar he wanted bar to
hold the news conference saying that
Trump broke no laws in his call with the
Ukrainian leader and bar declined to do
so according to the Washington Post the
requests from from traveled from the
President to other White House officials
and eventually to the Justice Department
right this is kind of what you need as I
said you need people around Trump to
just say no to him and if you have some
guardrails basically president Trump's
presidency is like bowling with my kids
there when I bought I don't need the I
don't need the bumpers in the lanes when
President Trump Bulls here he needs the
Mumper is in the lanes right it's good
it's good for him to have the bumpers
and
that's why he has people around him it
keeps the presidency on track the
requests from Trump traveled from the
president to other White House officials
and eventually to the Justice Department
the president has mentioned bars to
mural to associates in recent weeks
saying that he wished bar would have
held the news conference in recent weeks
the Justice Department has sought some
distance from the White House
particularly on matters related to this
burgeoning controversy people close to
the administration say that bar and
Trump remain on good terms and according
to Deputy White House press secretary
Hogan giddily the president has nothing
but respect for Ag bar and greatly
appreciates the work he's done on behalf
of the country again this is I think at
least in part an attempt by the media to
to again generate controversy within the
Trump administration by the way there
was some news yesterday they did not get
the kind of play that you would have
suspected it would get given the
contents of these impeachment hearings
and that is news surrounding kurt volker
so kurt volker was the special envoy to
the ukraine he did testify and his
testimony was released he did testify
that he didn't know anything about a
quid pro quo he said I did not know
there was a quid pro quo and when he was
confronted with the fact that ambassador
bill Taylor had suggested there was a
quid pro quo then then he said well no
in those texts he was asking if there
was a quid pro quo he wasn't saying he
knew if there was a quid pro quo so
President Trump tweeted out and he said
well thanks to Volcker for saying there
was no quid pro quo the fact is the only
way you're gonna know whether there was
a quote/unquote quid pro quo for
something corrupt is when you get Rudy
Giuliani in to testify all of this is
going to come down to Giuliani because
all the rest of it is third party
perception of action that was being
taken by Trump and Giuliani that's all
that's all okay meanwhile bad news for
Joe Biden there's another piece in
Politico tonight for a guy who's
supposedly non Shady he does a lot of
shady things for his family according to
Politico dot-com in 2013 an oil heiress
hired a Florida state senator to lobby
the federal government on behalf of a
pet cause banning the slaughter of
horses for me the lawmaker Joe Abruzzo
was a close associate of Frank Biden the
younger brother of then Vice President
Joe Biden at the time the younger Biden
was looking for state funding for his
charter school business and Abruzzo's
had on a key appropriations subcommittee
in the Florida Legislature the two men
met frequently says only natural that
when the horse slaughter measure stalled
in Congress Abruzzo saw it
Frank Biden's help as those involved
recounted
months later in videotaped remarks for
an equine welfare conference the VP
quickly went to back quote I also turn
to Frank and said we may need a little
help from the VP and the administration
talking to some senators said abruzzo
Biden and leaned on Mitch McConnell to
overcome the minority leaders objections
Frank Biden said on video my brother's
long-term relationships in the Senate
proved to be the final nail in the
coffin to be able to pull this thing
forward by the way Frank Biden and
Abruzzo run a lobbying business together
basically and get paid money for it in
fact
after Frank Biden and Abruzzo teamed up
on the horse measure after Abruzzo
received nearly $900,000 in lobbying
fees from his wealthy client the pair
teamed up again to lead the government
relations division of a law firm in
Florida where they've been pushing a
high-profile class-action lawsuit so
does it raise questions that Joe Biden's
family was doing business and Ukraine
particularly because as we've mentioned
over the past couple days there is now
some very solid information that hunter
Biden's firm that the the burries MA
firm had hired public relations
specialists to go to the State
Department and tried to have the State
Department relieve pressure on buries
mabye using hunter Biden's name write
that report was out there again from
John Sullivan who's been doing the
leading edge on this work according to
Ed Morrissey over at hot air basically
it looks as though Biden's son that firm
hired somebody to use hunter Biden's
names get access to the State Department
and a month later Joe Biden was talking
publicly about pressuring the prosecutor
to step down and Morrissey says that
certainly looks like the kind of
corruption of which House Democrats are
accusing Trump does it not at the very
least these emails undermine the idea
that Shokan wasn't being tough enough on
Purisima and that no one the Obama
administration connected the dots
between hunter Biden his dad and burries
MA it stinks of corruption and
interference for personal or familial
gain accurate and so they're still open
questions for Biden that are going to be
have to be answered here
all righty meanwhile meanwhile in the
2020 presidential race all of this is is
going to harm Joe Biden but Elizabeth
Warren is running into some headwinds
and those headwinds are coming from
people who actually know how business
works so people who are actually in the
business world lifelong Democrats are
looking at Elizabeth Warren and going no
no this is not a real human that I'm
going to vote for Bill Gates
who's a I mean real
lifelong Democrat he's given millions of
dollars to democratic causes Bill Gates
was on TV he warned Elizabeth Warren I'm
gonna vote for who is more professional
in 2020 and that may not be you given
all of your grandstanding about
corporations here's Bill Gates you know
make political declarations but I do
think no matter what policy somebody has
in mind a professional approach is even
as much as I disagree with some of the
policy things that are out there I do
think the professional approach to the
office whoever I decide would have the
more professional approach in the
current situation probably will way is
the thing that I'll weigh the most and
you know I hope the more professional
candidate is an electable candidate okay
what he means by that is Elizabeth
Warren is a crazy person by the way
Elizabeth Warren then fired back at Bill
Gates because this is her stick
suggesting that she wants to meet with
Bill Gates and talk about his wealth tax
she does I'm always happy to meet with
people even if we have different views
Bill Gates if we get the chance I'd love
to explain exactly how much you'd pay
under my wealth tax I promise it's not a
hundred billion dollars no you're just
going to devastate the wealth of people
who have earned it Bill Gates didn't pay
his taxes and it gives an awful lot of
charity and Elizabeth Warren is an awful
awful liar I'm just terrible so there it
is you know even in the business
community is turning against Elizabeth
Warren which is of course why all of the
focus is going into impeachment already
time for a thing I like and then a thing
that I hate so things that I like today
so Jeff Sessions is going to run for
Senate in Alabama now this has drawn the
ire of a lot of people it's drawn the
ire of the White House the White House
keeps saying well we don't like Jeff
Sessions jeff Sessions is a bad Attorney
General actually Jeff Sessions a pretty
good Attorney General right Jeff
Sessions being in that slot basically
prevented Trump from engaging in
activity that probably would have
resulted in this impeachment inquiry two
years sooner and people rip on Jeff
Sessions Jeff Sessions was the first
senator in the United States Senate to
endorse President Trump he was a
longtime ally of Trump and Trump just
crapped all over him he's a guy who
received very bad treatment at president
Trump's hands in from piss still
retained all of his advisers right
Stephen Miller was eight was a Jeff
Sessions guy before all of this started
as sessions is going to announce that
he's running for Senate in Alabama why
am i happy about that because the reason
that the Alabama sentence here right now
is being
held by a Democrat Doug Jones is because
the Republicans like idiots nominated
Roy Moore an alleged creeper going after
fourteen-year-old girls at the food
court allegedly right and right now that
there are people in the Republican
parties and we don't need Jeff Sessions
in this race
we don't need Jeff Sessions in this race
why because a crowded field
representative Bradley Byrne republican
of alabama former auburn university
coach Tommy Tuberville Secretary of
State John Merrill
Stanley Adair State Representative
Arnold Mooney and Roy Moore and people
like well that is it that's a crowded
field why do we need one more candidate
that's why you need sessions in there
really if you're a Republican and you
want to see that route that's he be read
the only thing they'll prevent that seat
from going right literally the only
thing is if Roy Moore is the nominee if
Roy Moore is the nominee he is not
making it into the Senate Doug Jones is
gonna himself another term like a full
term not in a special election okay so
what that requires is somebody who can
actually consolidate support behind them
the problem with a crowded field is who
is the biggest name in that field the
only two big names in that field are
Tommy Tuberville and Roy Moore okay and
there's a good shot that Roy Moore is
able to consolidate his base to a much
stronger extent than anybody else in the
field sessions was a longtime senator
from Alabama coming back in and sweeping
to victory with 65% vote would be a very
good thing for the Republican Party the
fact that Trump has personal animus for
sessions should not prevent the
Republican Party of Alabama from
actually putting a Republican back in
the Senate
apparently sessions has yet to speak
with Senate Majority Leader Mitch
McConnell or Senator Todd young the
chairman of the Senate GOP campaign arm
sessions has actually not talked to
trump or vice president Pence either
although the White House has
communicated to sessions inner circle
they would view his candidacy extremely
unfavorably the operative said the one
thing you wanted in 2020 is to ensure
that the Alabama race is not a national
news story if it's a no-drama
affair the outcome isn't in doubt yeah
but it will be a drama affair because
Roy Moore is gonna run again so what you
need is a name who is one before the
operative said sessions is the favorite
in the primary if trump decides to
embark on a tweet storm it changes
everything right so tell Trump not to do
it
tell Trump not to do it I'm sorry but if
Trump's personal animus causes
Republicans to lose the Alabama Senate
seat again that is unforgivable
politically speaking it's insanity
insanity Jeff Sessions should run and
Trump should stop it and that's the end
of that story okay time for a quick
thing that I hate
okay so beta O'Rourke is out of the race
but not out of our hearts I mean he was
never really in our hearts maybe no
works the works but beta O'Rourke still
cruising the land and he has decided
that he is going to be a resistance hero
and he's gonna lobby hard for that
commentary spot on MSNBC but she's been
aiming for that Saturday morning slot
it's wide open for a beta comeback bra
well beta is now going around saying
that the American flag is too negative
to display by the way this if this beta
work had run in Texas against Ted Cruz
he gets shellacked this is not the beta
walking around in Texas and lost by two
points this is the beta overall if he
ran in Texas would get Wendy Davis style
numbers in a gubernatorial race I here's
beta or rogue saying that the American
flag is too negative to display at a
time that we seek to repair the damage
done following the legacy of slavery and
segregation and Jim Crow and and
suppression I think it's really
important to take into account the
impression that that that kind of symbol
would have for many of our fellow
Americans also respect the decision that
Nike made okay so we can't display the
American flag it's too divisive if you
can't display the American flag in
America I would suggest that you might
think about whether there's a future for
you in the country like this I don't see
why this is super controversial I got
listen you have a right to burn the flag
you have a right to kneel on the flag
you were right to do all of those things
but if you believe that the America if
you actually believe like as a
politician that the American flag itself
is too divisive not all the issues that
you're associating with the American
flag the flag itself is too divisive
then there's no future for the country
so why would you stay here bitter or
work again signifying the ED of the
Democratic base and that is ugly ugly
stuff okay we'll be back here later
today with two additional hours of
content also speaking at Stanford
University tonight make sure that you
watch the young America's Foundation
livestream will also be live-streaming
it from our from our Facebook accounts
and all the rest so go check that out
tonight otherwise we'll see you here
tomorrow I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
assistant director Pavo wide outski
edited by Adam sy events audio is mixed
by Mike Cora Mina hair and makeup is by
Joshua alvera production assistant Nick
Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
19 hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host
of the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon is
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew clip
[Music]